[Music]
okay all right what the hell
address the Jewish Question that's a
hell of a thing to ask
so that's Jaqueline turn you know I mean
really that's a hell of a thing to ask
but I will say something about it you
know and I've thought about this a lot
so there is evidence that ask a nosy
Jews so those are Jews of European
heritage have IQs that are about 15
points higher than the population
average so that's a lot 15 points it's
about the average difference between the
typical high school student and the
typical state college student it's a lot
and one of the things that means is so
imagine there's two distributions and
that they overlap and that the Jewish
one is is the the mean is as one 15 so
the whole distribution is shifted to the
right what that means is if you go up
into the higher IQ strata 131 45 way the
hell up there that Jewish people are
overwhelmingly over-represented at the
high end of the IQ distribution now the
price they pay for that is some
increased propensity for neurological
diseases that seems to be associated in
some sense with that heightened IQ now
you know the science on this isn't
settled but but it's reasonably solid
you know given the standards of such
things okay so Jews are gonna be
over-represented at the high end of
cognitively complex disciplines so then
I would say and that's the case like
their way over-represented among like
outstanding scientists and among Nobel
Prize winners and and so forth and so
you know people look and they think well
why are there a disproportionate number
of Jewish people in positions of
authority and they say well it must be a
conspiracy you know it must be systemic
in some sense it's like no it can be
simply accounted for by that relatively
large IQ differential
now the next criticism would be well
don't the Jews tend to lean left
well first you might say well you know
given what happened in in Nazi Germany
to the degree that that was right-wing
as we discussed earlier that's the
nationalism and ethnocentrism it's
hardly surprising that they might you
know in this historical period of time
tend to move towards the left
but more importantly than that IQ is
associated with trade openness and trade
openness is a strong predictor predictor
of political liberalism so and it's the
strongest predictor of political
liberalism so you know it's very
difficult so that's what I have to say
about that it's like and the other thing
I would say is you know the fact that
there's a population as sub population
of people who are much smarter than
average not on average right on average
I've you gotta get that straight on
average is actually of great benefit to
the rest of us because what do you want
fewer geniuses fewer people with IQs of
145 or 160 that's and you know and it's
no conspiracy that puts people who are
smarter higher up in competence
hierarchies because IQs the best
predictor of movement up in a complex
called competence hierarchy so there
I've addressed the Jewish Question it's
like it's a confusion between ethnicity
and and IQ as far as I'm concerned so
I'll probably get like painted six
different shades of black for that
answer but it's I've thought about a
long time it's the best that I can
manage